[Music]
put it there wait have you washed your
hands um I may have some hand sanitizer
we've been shaking hands since as early
as 1800 BCE when we thought we could
absorb the Gods power
well we're absorbing something all right
research has shown that we have over
3,000 bacteria on our hands including
fecal matter from 150 different species
rose to make matters worse the average
person shakes hands 15,000 times in
their lifetime so what if we stopped
shaking hands all together would losing
the handshake make a difference or would
it just be replaced by something even
more yucky this is what if and here's
what would happen if we stopped shaking
hands it's believed that shaking hands
started as a gesture to show you meant
no harm to others this was done by
reaching out the right hand where your
weapon would normally be and showing
that it was empty
the classic hand movement of up and down
could have been a way to show there were
no knives or daggers hidden in the arm
see nothing up my sleeve since then it's
become a gesture of good faith and
commitment often used when closing a
deal and that's just scratching the
surface of why we shake hands cultures
around the world have different
variations of who shakes hands and how
but all involve getting touchy-feely
which isn't doing much good for our
health
when we shake hands and our hands have
large amounts of bacteria or viruses on
them we spread the bacteria or viruses
to the people we shake hands with this
increases the chances of people getting
sick
but let's say you just washed your hands
great but it doesn't mean much if the
other person didn't so the bacteria
train keeps on chugging the transmission
of common colds and the flu have both
been linked to handshakes and the longer
the handshake the higher the odds of
catching something most doctors agree
that cutting out handshakes would hugely
benefit our health but is it that easy
we're not just taking away a gesture
we're taking away a concept that's been
ingrained in our cultures for centuries
so we need to find a replacement what if
we lived in a world where after you
secured a multibillion-dollar deal
everyone in the meeting high-fived well
good news high fives
transmitted half as much bacteria as a
standard handshake and if you really
want to seal the deal
fist bumps transmitted even fewer
bacteria what if our greetings didn't
involve touching at all hmm that
wouldn't work for me I'm a hugger what
if in the future we just tipped our hats
now if we need to bring top hats back
into fashion for that
what about saluting or the peace sign
that was all the rage in the 60s man we
could bow wave or do the namaste ritual
if it were up to us we'd be using the
Vulcan live long and prosper gesture
that hurts worse than uniform so could
we do it sure we could researchers at
Carleton University in Ottawa say that
we're living in a time of heightened
disease awareness called a pandemic
culture it's changing the way we behave
in public interact with each other and
it's making us aware that everything we
touch is covered in microbes so how
would we get people to stop shaking
hands
well consider this smoking used to be a
cultural norm but as research showed its
health risks and public education
campaigns educated us about the dangers
of smoking the norm changed not smoking
is now the cultural norm what if we used
this model to change people's tendency
to shake hands into some other form of
greeting mass media and the internet
would make it easy to spread information
about the danger of shaking hands
this would encourage people to adopt
other practices agencies such as the
United Nations the World Health
Organization and the Centers for Disease
Control could agree on practices to
replace handshakes that would transmit
less bacteria and viruses between people
and if we really wanted to guarantee
that people would change the greedy's
legislation could discourage or
downright prohibit the use of handshakes
we know that we need a way to connect
with each other the physical contact of
shaking hands is a tried-and-true method
used in both formal and informal
situations but there are other ways we
can connect assess each other and
indicate genuine intentions if we stop
shaking hands it would be safer for
everyone but hey why stop at handshakes
there are plenty of other ways that
germs spread what if we went to the
extreme and held in every single one of
our sneezes well that's a story for
another what if